what's up believe nation welcome back to
another YouTube hangout I'm excited to
be here again with my friend Stephen
Kelly CEO of the amazing sage software
company it's what I use to power my
accounting for this business and today
we're gonna be talking about the first
steps in starting the business and the
biggest mistakes to avoid Stephen Kelly
welcome back sir
great if you've a Kevin gray to be on
your broadcast I think you're doing
amazing stuff
and today we're obviously got some
future entrepreneurs out there and if we
can give some pearls of wisdom so
they've become rock stars of the future
in the business world where we're doing
a great job I love it well we're we're
used to our tradition people people will
not let it go unless we start with
Stephen Kelly quotes so what do you have
for us this month we're gonna do
Kelly clips this month are some like bee
industry name quotes and then a few from
myself so today's quotes about starting
a business is the best way to predict
the future is to invent it but I really
got Peter Drucker a famous economist
author buy the next one a genius again
in these time vision without execution
is just hallucination a great Henry Ford
of motor coughing and the last one throw
my barbara corcoran from shark tank
ah never underestimate the power of your
own instinct and then some Kelly quotes
to kick it into gear now so true
entrepreneurs have the vision to see
what others don't
entrepreneurs dream second quote no
matter what the political or social
climate entrepreneurs will always always
see the opportunity and now final one in
terms of getting right back to the topic
always put yourself in the shoes of the
customer will they buy a product always
start from there
the customer so with that and back to
you I love it I love all people in the
chat are loving it somebody's writing
quotes with like 10 exclamation points
after so it's great some writing to say
is the is this gonna be live later you
can watch the replay just give it about
30
minutes after we're done and you can
watch the replay to live on YouTube
forever Steven and I want to be able to
answer your questions we're talking
about the first steps in starting the
business big mistakes of void so if you
tagged me in the chat it's easier for me
to pick them up but before I turn it
over to the chat Steven what would you
say let's take one one first step that
you take and one mistake to avoid what
do you got um I'll go a crazy way to
style this one and I think I like the
golden word is moonlight so it's a great
way to start a business while you being
you're on the payroll of someone else so
you can carve out time in the evenings
and weekends and what you really want to
do if hand that glide path where you
start your business you like that ever
you like that I like and I get on a roll
you've got first customers you go to
product out there and it's going really
well and when it's going really well you
jump off the cliff and resign and then
you know you're you're a sure bet so
definitely worth and I know loads of
amazing entrepreneurs actually Marc
Benioff from Salesforce which is what
value look I think probably eighty
billion dollars on his company he
started it when he was working at Oracle
and effectively moonlighted and stunned
his dream of his own company that
transformed the world around clout and
huge credit to him amazing company but
so think about that moon right how do
you get funded to keep a roof over your
head and you know all the things you
need to do but how do you actually get
the momentum around your business to get
the idea get it going and start your
business so that's just a little word of
the day and what would you say is the
biggest mistake to avoid I think
actually do you know what there's a lot
of temptation I think this has been
smashed by the digital economy and
social media is people just take too
long to get to market so many
entrepreneurs aren't known they just
just spend too much time almost analysis
paralysis looking at markets looking at
playing around with product design and
and they operate in a vacuum for some
reason I think great entrepreneurs tend
to have that bias traction kind of just
do it now and
they kind of bring product to market
really really quickly and almost almost
test-drive it so they get like focus
group and it could be through social
media where they get real-life opinions
from potential customers and they go
where the audiences and they do a lot of
this sort of R&D on the customers dime
so i would i would always fear the
biggest mistake you can make is taken
too long taken too long I'll seize the
moment you know a bit of Latin here for
everybody carpe diem seize the moment
and get stuck in and get your product
Ella I love it all right let's turn it
over to the audience guys you have a
question for me and Steven tagged me in
the chat and we'll get to as many as we
can in our session here today up first
is Lin Hussain what is the oldest person
you know who started a business and
became successful the oldest person that
you've known who started the business
and became successful one of the ìiî
known a lot of entrepreneurs in their
seventies and it's a different variation
actually on moonlight a lot of
entrepreneurs have started their
business certainly in their 40s and 50s
when they've been part of a RIF
reduction in force say from a US company
and they've been kind of laid off and
they get a check from the company for
their years of service and they've used
that check to you know supplement maybe
a pension but also actually as as the
equity to start their business the cash
to fund their dreams a lot of people you
know I I've heard people say friends of
mine who'd started a business in 40s or
50s
said you know the day I got laid off for
my company was the best day of my life
it was a defining moment because it cut
me free and it cut all the insecurities
away from me and I doubled down and
lived a business my dreams there's a guy
who's approaching his 80th birthday
successful entrepreneur Canadian a guy
called Gordon Weissman he's a Lord
actually and he's a successful
entrepreneur and a lot of his
entrepreneurial activities started in
70s so I think the great news about
today yes at age another actually sorry
go on
Kevin is I was with that an incredible
entrepreneur he's part of the equivalent
shark tank over in Europe called
Dragon's Den a very sick
foreigner Peter Jones probably owns
about 38 companies now but he's set up a
foundation of the foundation is a
funding agency for entrepreneurs to get
their sort of seed capital and they give
it it's an amazing project these gives
it they give out you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars but it's basically
you can get a thousand pounds so about
fourteen hundred dollar loan and you
have you repay if you're successful but
they get a return alike eighty-eight
percent so just shows all these amazing
young people starting businesses but the
converse is they do entrepreneurship
training for as young as five year olds
five year old so they go from five to
twenty five but now they're doing this
program where they're getting very
entrepreneur's in right at the get-go so
I don't think age is a problem you know
so I know now I met some entrepreneurs
yesterday who was 17 years old blew me
away with their passion their energy
their ambition so you know I think age
is definitely not a factor there's a
wall that you can smash through so
easily the two that come to mind for me
of all they're entrepreneurs that are
kind of household names one is Ray Kroc
we started McDonald's we did in the 60s
and he has a famous quote that I'm gonna
butcher but something around you know he
was past a prime of his life and he had
kidney disease or half his liver removed
and diabetes like all this stuff that
you know now it's supposed to be wind
down time and and mail it in but that's
just when he started McDonald's and
built a huge brain the others Colonel
Sanders who started KFC and it was in
his 70s that he was starting to build it
up and franchise it out
and so yeah I agree with Stevens just a
number
yeah go ahead yeah yeah actually a great
movie to watch is the movie about a year
ago about the story of McDonald's and
Roy Crocker and the brothers down in
California who who were the kind of
original McDonald's it is all the best
and the worst of entrepreneurship but it
just gives you a fantastic insight into
the story of one of the the most
successful brands in the world yeah I
think it's called the founder yeah it is
I think yeah we'll check that out it's
definitely worth definitely worth a
90-minute kind of
Netflix yeah cool all right love it next
I'll got this is the opposite end I've
been it Stephen can you give us some
ideas as an 18 year old for how to make
money yeah I think I'm so the kind of
first thing is obviously I've talked
about moonlight and the first thing
really you're going to do is have an
idea so and the way you do this is if
you're a consumer if you're frustrated
about seeing a gap in the market or a
need that you've got that's not being
met that's a great way to kind of focus
on it you know I know everyone loves
things like salsa dancing
there's probably gaps in the market
around salsa dancing classes stuff
online so so I think it has to be
something you're passionate about
something you love and something you
know about and if you do then you can
see gaps and opportunities and then once
you've got the idea and it could be a
service could be a product then once
you've got that is kind of go and do
some testing on the audience of
potential audience great way to do that
is social media and then just put a
really kind of skeleton business plan
together how you're gonna get to market
and grow your business and and how
you're gonna get enough cash to be
successful it's funny the first two
questions are both about age and from
opposite ends of the spectrum yeah it's
interesting to see how a lot of young
people coming up say I'm well I'm too
young to start and then older people say
well I'm too old to start it's like when
are you a perfect age you're never the
right age to start like now is the right
age to start just start whatever age you
are just go and start it's crazy the
kind of stories and excuses we came up
with I think it's never been easier to
win as a young entrepreneur young people
have never had more respect in
businesses in in the economy you know
you don't see very many 65 year old
Instagram account managers right and so
I try to lean in on the things that to
Stevens Point you're passionate about
you really love doing and the thing that
as a young person you have an advantage
over so anything online anything with
social media anything with you know
video content all of that stuff is
something that my parents generation
they didn't grow up with and they have a
harder time wrapping their head around
and so that's where they're looking like
the the executives are looking to the
youth to say hey I need help with this
can you help me with my with my
marketing with my social media with my
online content pair that with a passion
with salsa dancing with whatever it is
you're interested in and it's a quick
way to start building a business yeah I
mean you're so right you know 10 years
is so changed so if you're 18 years old
almost certainly you'll be future
competent on social media be surf in the
channels you'll be posting content out
on YouTube you'll be really smart and
you know the essence of what you want to
do as a business entrepreneur
is build trust you know build that
magical word of trust 10 years ago it
took years to build trust now through
social media you can become a really
trusted BAM super quick if you become a
thought leader you provide really
intelligent blogs you know who would
have guessed that probably one of the
biggest brands in the world is the
Kardashians yeah
unimaginable so so what it means is the
potentially you've got you're a team and
you're really kind of socially adept
then I think there's a fantastic
platform out there to really get your
big idea
are launched I love it there's so many
questions coming in we picked a good
topic today you could think think Daryl
Daryl eyes Stephens
right-hand man they're on on marketing
and content and he picked the topic
today so if you guys would like him it
think Darrell okay let's try to get
through as many as we can Salima is
saying Evan and Steven can you please
provide some tips to manage your cash
flow while starting the business yes
Elena that's really good yeah cash is
the fuel of the business because you
know any and I guess from an accounting
point of view obviously it's important
to be profitable but actually you don't
you don't kind of kill a business
because you're not profitable you
actually wind up a business when you run
out of cash so I'd say a few things one
is some be smart be creative be
thoughtful so put a skeleton business
plan together that has a kind of weekly
monthly cash flow forecasts in terms of
projected sales what's a cost and then I
think there's a great thing for
entrepreneurs to be Hustlas see how do I
get
my traductor market is cheaper as
possible even better get other people to
pay for distribution other people to pay
for different things or partnerships so
I think partnerships happen to be super
smart secondly friends and family people
who know you are if you've got an idea
and you've tested it with a community
group around set of salsa dancing or
something like that then go to them and
say you love my idea do you want to
invest ah the other thing I sort of hint
at is I think it's really quite did this
one of the businesses I was involved in
15 years ago actually got customers to
become very small equity owners in the
business and see I didn't know how smart
it was at the time but I decided that we
wouldn't basically give up all the 10%
of the stock so there's a miniscule
amount of stock we gave them but boy oh
boy when he got customers as
shareholders as well they've got such a
strong vested interest in your success
so I think just think of creative ways
how do I get cash and then the obvious
things just run the business you know
particularly furs are you know got an
e-commerce store front and it's online
then you want to get paid straightaway
you you ideally you want to create a
business model where you get paid when
the transaction is done and then you
actually only ship the product after
you've got the cash in the bank so you
incur and all the benefits from the cash
and you may be actually different some
of the production cost of the product so
just think about how I defer any expense
how do I maximize the cash that I'm
going to receive from customers partners
and how do I get really creative around
being a hustler and doing the right
things to grow the business and preserve
the cash because and also obvious kind
of stuff like you know if you live a
mile from the office
don't take ooh but don't take taxis walk
you and get get a cycle you know just
just preserve everything you can because
every dollar you spend I every company
I've started I've said treat the
company's money as if it's your own
because what's an entrepreneur it is so
every dollar you Burton is a dollar
you're not invested in your product or
your brand or your marked if anybody's
following Stephen on Instagram you'll
see
a cycling outfit that is going on now
training for a big big event coming up
next Monday next Monday and hey guys
this is a kind of bit off piste about
four months ago I said they're doing a
big safe Foundation charity right and
it's for disadvantaged kids in the north
of England fantastic charity called
chromatin and they take basically kids
that have been given up by schools and
society and they create an environment
and training the support in a safe
environment that they give them an
opportunity as well as trend to be
entrepreneurs and give them skills so
it's fantastic charity so the guys say
don't need to do this about a 300 mile
cycle ride start a cycle guys you know I
thought I just can't say no to a
challenge so I said how do you do well
do the first leg so the first leg is
other than 80 miles will sign now just
just bring the story forward Evan four
weeks ago I went to a store and say can
i bar bike because I went online we said
actually go into your local stores and I
said can I buy mine
so you say yeah we'll be so your bicycle
thousands of buy it's great could I take
one list of all we have to get you
fitted and measured and all this sort of
stuff I said how long will it take
he said probably about 45 minutes so
there's all kind of computerized really
high tech anyway 45 minutes later I said
what can I do by now and he said no you
have to get the bike built now we've got
all the measurements all the
specification so I had to wait two more
weeks for the bike so this week I was
out there five o'clock in the morning I
think you can see on Instagram do my
kind of pre pre runs and I was really
concerned about these two things one is
the gear so I have to go on YouTube to
find out how to work the gears the other
thing is these things called cleats
so if you're not into cycling you won't
understand what I'm talking about but
your shoes are not like old pedals they
kind of clip in and get hard kind of
Ratchet it into the pedals and you can't
remove them so I had to check out on
YouTube because everybody says I
guarantee you'll fall over Steven before
you've even started cycling so you do on
these bike and you just go boom like
that so good news is fingers crossed
so far I'm not falling over I don't fall
training runs
and I'm ready for it now Evan so I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna win the Tour de
France but I might just survive a day
cycling and do 80 marks and it's always
very grateful as charity and how much
you raising for charity we're well over
I think I overall for the team I think
is well over $20,000 now but we got a
target to push that up and it is part of
the million dollar challenge our CFO
chief financial officer I'm Steve hair
is personally sponsoring this Cramerton
a youth volunteering project and he's
committed to do this million-dollar
challenge so he's been riding and
running all over the world for this
charity and so I'm doing it for Steve my
buddy nice and CFO so anybody wants to
kind of sponsor me I'm not proud I'll
take it all when it's for a great cause
great cause for the future for those
kids I love it well you're getting Wow
80 miles in the comments Steven good job
so you got some people cheering you on I
feel like Daryl needs to be cycling next
to you and like Instagram live feed the
whole the whole Stephen Kelly 80 miles
I'll see you mind with a tow he should
tow me dammit he should he should be
cited by like a like a disconnected
tandem and I should be on October 8
behind it especially on the hills only
on the hills Darrell that you got anyway
we need to bring Darrell in every now
and then it's done a great job okay back
on track so the comment was around cash
flow I love Stevens Point oh that's my
fault for derailing us I think it's just
about not spending money till you're
making money and the mindset of moving
from how am I gonna start this with no
money to how am I gonna start this with
no money just shifting the belief system
you can do it and asking the right
question with the right tonality
resourcefulness is the ultimate resource
even little things like yesterday Alex
came over he helps to run TDs and he
makes his tea every morning and he
didn't bring his tea strainer thing so I
was like how am I gonna make my tea and
instead of giving up he used a little
lemon squeezer thing to put his tea in
there and water through it and he made
his tea it's just fun there's always a
way it's finding a way and that's
story of every entrepreneur that you
look up to nobody was just handed a
million dollars to say hey go run your
business right it's always these crazy
resourcefulness things that they do to
get going and I would just study and
model the people who you love and look
up to and look at how they started their
business and that gives you inspiration
as well as ideas and what you can do hey
here's an FM quote the answer is never
more resources it's always more
resourceful Ness
I like that I'm gonna put down on my
Instagram I love it okay Rogaine this
this ties into your moonlighting idea
how do you balance a nine-to-five ain't
starting up at the same time well I
think and and have a kind of social life
and fun and stuff like that because you
want it whatever you do is not to play
you never want to lose sight of you
wanna have fun I think Roedean I think
the reality is obviously you know your
employer you do 95 job you've got to do
a good job there but as soon as you get
out there you know one minute past 5:00
you were gonna be really thinking about
how do I kind of use that evening wisely
because time as an entrepreneur you've
got to keep time as your friend when
time becomes your enemy you're chasing
your tail
the overvaluing routine is you you could
probably hopefully work depends what
sort of company you work for but you you
do find managers who are quite
sympathetic to young entrepreneurs and
they'll cut you some slack and give you
a bit of time at work to do some stuff
and maybe use a few other resources
around and talk to some other colleagues
at work to bounce ideas off so I think
in fact amazing person who runs our AIT
pair pretty Sharma she's a genius Forbes
under 30 top 30 woman all that she's
done their own business we've been
fantastically supportive and in fact we
give them a sea capital for that
business as well so there's a load of
things I would always again back to
Evans point just reset and reframe their
problem instead of seeing your employer
as a kind of straightjacket for you see
your employee a current employer as a
way to fund number one the cash but
number two the ideas the inventiveness
some of the resources and very often
you'll find great managers who are very
supportive have you living your dreams
and spreading your wings and starting
your own business
nice back to the story of resource alone
s Bernadette is sharing my cousin is
addicted to coffee he wanted some and
mine was broken he brewed coffee through
one of my clean socks and darryl is in
the chat saying no cycling for me
evan towers of rooks I want a big shout
out for del Darrell's got his own
following he's a rock star he looks
great he is great he makes everything
that I do on social media amplifies the
volume he's big shout out for now maybe
we need to make Darrell run next year
for 80 miles and I'll give him up we'll
give him a gimbal so it doesn't shake
too much and I feel like part of his
performance review should involve
cycling in this race or running with you
how to balance 95 and set it up I would
say wine I like Stephens idea of like
how do you how do you leverage the
company that you're at so ideally the
point of having a job is to learn so
you're taking this business to learn and
not just collect the paycheck and then
to out you just have to schedule it in
like anything that's important you
schedule in and it's interesting how
much we'll let ourselves down but we
won't let other people down like you
have a meeting with your boss or being
with your client or meeting with a
friend and you'll show up for that
meeting but if it's if you come home
from your job when you're tired and you
and you say hey I've scheduled in an
hour a day for my business and often
you'll just let that go say I'm too
tired I'm not going to work on my
business that that's when you set the
identity I think as soon as you set a
goal for yourself every time you you do
the thing then you build self-respect
like Steven took on his crazy challenge
he has a identity of I take on
challenges and I'm gonna go and crush
them that that builds his self-respect
and every time you don't do it if you
say hey I'm gonna go in cycle and then
if you don't do it you lose self respect
for yourself and so you know be very
careful when you commit to but then when
you do it if you say you're gonna work
an hour a day on your business then you
have to work an hour or day on your
business you should go to bed around
like 10:00 10:30 last night it was up to
11 with a fellow youtuber I came home
and I have in my goals that I I want to
run for half an hour and then I could do
I ruined my rotator cuff so I have some
rehab that have to do for half an hour
so I got home at 11:00 and like I still
have to run for half an hour and I still
have to do my rotator cuff for half an
hour and then take the dogs down it's
like 12:15 outside with the dogs you
know two hours past and I'm supposed to
be but that builds your self-respect
when you do the thing even though it's
hard to do the thing it doesn't build
your self-respect when you do the thing
that's easier to do yeah that's so true
they say and and I think if you're as an
entrepreneur you love you you dream so
much you know things like I don't I
wouldn't profess this but for me I say
things like sleep there's plenty of time
for sleep in the next life
we're here to you know make something
special happen as entrepreneurs and I
think the other thing just right back to
your question if you can be super smart
you're probably going to work for a
company where you're gonna get some
ideas as well and then you have to be
super careful about not crossing the
line in terms of stealing intellectual
property and all that sort of stuff but
the number of property companies are no
consulting companies you know real
estate companies where they've worked
for one of the big franchises and then
they've gone off to start their you know
almost Beauty lives so many different
industries where entrepreneurs have been
spawned and really kind of nurtured from
the big companies so that's even better
because then you know kind of the
business model you know what works you
know what customers want you might even
know customers you taik to your new new
adventure so there's so many
opportunities to their wild and kind of
just working in McDonald's and then
saying I'm gonna invent you know a drone
or something like that so I think if you
work in a business that's pretty related
then there's massive impact and every
day you go to work you know I know this
you say our if I'm a my own business if
this was my business I'll do that
differently you've got so many ideas and
it's about channeling those ideas and
then taking them off to really live your
own adventure and start business I love
it okay next Amanda Evan and Stephen do
you believe that social media needs to
be a part of a company what if you
aren't interested in social media
I think now probably the only successful
business that ignore social media is
probably businesses that sell to the NSA
or security services I really struggle
even I'm just trying to think in
business-to-business do these social
media yeah business consumer I think if
you you know Amanda
whether you like social media or not
truthfully it's just part of the fabric
of success for an entrepreneur and and I
find you know again it's probably
reframing how you think about social
media it's just a conversation yeah but
it allows you to have a conversation
with millions of people thousands of
followers customers partners and and
provide and really provide that for
leadership to take the conversation
further to next level so again one of
these things is entrepreneur I think
it's so easy for us all you know just as
human beings to fear stuff fear the
unknown fear new stuff and I think as
entrepreneurs the more we kind of take
that first step of trying new stuff the
more confident we've become the more we
believe and evidence the master this in
terms of reframing the problem reading
the books on a shelf next to the great
pictures you know you you will be so
much more powerful I promise you if you
really engage intelligently on social
media because it's just such a fantastic
way to really fuel your growth in your
business and create a volunteer army
around you who can help you with your
business dreams yeah I think it just
depends on the size of your ambition I
think you know if you want to be a
personal trainer and you were a really
good personal trainer you could build up
a business just through referrals of
being a good personal trainer and be
booked solid yourself and slowly
increase your prices and you have a good
kind of lifestyle business but to scale
it to something big I don't know how you
do it without using marketing and social
media is the easiest way to get a
message out I would also encourage you
to think along the lines of what Stephen
is talking about
shifting the mindset you know
entrepreneurs we start a business
because we're on a mission like you see
something in the world that you're not
happy with and back to his Drucker quote
at the beginning the best way to predict
the future is to create it I think I
think if you are mission driven and it's
your responsibility to share it to move
people if you really believe in
something it's your responsibility to go
out and make that happen not just for
the ten clients that you have around you
and the people closest to you but for
the world
it's I think it's your responsibility to
speak up so those two things I think you
can build a small business just two
referrals and providing the great
service or product but if you want to
scale and if you are mission driven then
I think getting onboard social media is
gonna be really helpful for you all
right what else we've got some
interesting ones coming up okay let's go
with Cypress evidence Stephen how would
you push an app a business I've created
an app and I even have companies that
want to partner up but I still need to
get downloads how can I promote it he
suffers I think a great way with that
business is obviously you've got a
product you got an app you've got to get
it out there so you could probably want
to join some sort of ecosystem
we've got micro marketplace Salesforce
go marketplace lots of companies they've
got a marketplace where you can post
your app and and then actually engage
your community of particular through
social media and start a conversation
with customers so you want to with all
these things you probably I know what
stage of product development you are but
hopefully you kind of gone through alpha
BT you've had some people using the app
and they like the app and then it's just
really what's the best commercial model
but there's some bases you can get this
these apps hosted and you just Pam kind
of pennies per click cents per click in
terms of the downloads and so there's
there's a number of and actually in this
era there's a ton of stuff on the
internet that helps you in terms of
other folks who have gone the journey
you're on so if you got a product ready
I'll say kind of check it out spend a
couple of hours looking our websites
around how they can launch
it's business there's tons of resources
around there are materials and then also
you know on this sort of area that sort
of back to Amanda's previous point is I
think it's great again through social
media to actually reach out to some of
the experts in your field so wouldn't it
be great to talk to an entrepreneur and
two years ago launch that the business
has been shoot you successful because
they also tell you what the bear traps
are what the mistakes they made and
again you can find people are hugely
generous for their time so I think it's
a really hot area really good area and
the obviously is part of that you want a
really good social presence yourself and
a really good digital presence with the
website and all the kind of supporting
material around your product and in this
case an app so I mean a great
opportunity the best it sounds like
you're ready for Showtime ready for
Showtime I love that that could be a
thing
Darrell let's make some Instagram
content ready for Showtime Amanda from
the last question by the way is writing
in to say thank you to all caps with
like 20 exclamation marks and four giant
happy faces so I would agree with
Stephen here Cypress what I would add is
I would try to work with influencers who
are in the space and get them using the
tool and if they like it they'll help
promote it and a lot of that doesn't
have to be paid if it's good right I
mean if if you're targeting
entrepreneurs with your tool and it
really works that I'm somebody you want
to talk to if you're targeting people
who do makeup then there's lots of
people who you can talk to you about
those things if your thing works then
finding the people who can be those
influencers for you and if they can use
it in their business then they will talk
about you right and you don't
necessarily have to pay for anything I
wouldn't be looking for advertising
shoutouts yet so if you're kind of
starting up you don't have any budget
but show them how it's gonna help them
in their business and there's plenty of
tools that I've used that people giving
me for free to test out and try and I
use them in my business and then I end
up telling people about them because I
actually use them in my business
and so I try to make my list of who
would be great users for your app who
have a following and go connect with
them online in person
however you need to make the
introduction get them using it then you
have to see like does it work is your
thing good yeah actually I'm just on
this you might not listed this is an
important that's all about belief I on
this cycling geek so I've obviously just
downloaded an app because the guys said
they're all on this app I won't tell you
the name of it beating all guess it
starts with s so I'm not gonna go
product placement for but it starts with
s followed by T anyway I had a free app
the free app I used to use was more
functionally rich than the app that I
mentioned starts with s but why is the S
app kind of taking over the world and
going crazy I'm running and cycling I'm
getting loads of profile in the poured
sheet news media because they brought a
community everybody in the community is
using this app so it may not be always
the best app or the most functionally
rich product but you want to build that
kind of volunteer army around it of the
community so Evans idea about getting
some thought leaders you know if it's
like fitness or a health or beauty or
any of these if you can get like
celebrity endorsement classic product
placement and get them on social media
to endorse your app then wow you're just
ready for take off
I love it next one oh you're gonna like
this one because you care so much about
customers Henry is ready into say
evidence Stephen what is the best thing
you can do to make up with a
disappointed client
Henry so I I just think kind of from the
get-go any company Golden Rule is just
be obsessed about customers and just
live in their shoes every day and what
that means you know and in terms of all
this I think all entrepreneurs have got
great integrity but you are running out
a thousand miles on that you know
reality is you always want to aspire to
have the best customer service you know
par excellence
however you know if particular when you
scale a business we got well over three
million customers sometimes yeah it's
inevitable that you drop a ball because
you just can't even even the best
customer services that will they make
cell phones or fly aeroplanes or
whatever they do you can't get the
experience
perfect every time 24:07 all over the
world is probably just perfections not
available on this planet so what it
means is as the entrepreneur you've got
to step in there and you've got to leave
from the front and you've got to say to
everybody as you grow your company we
always always to look for customers you
know like rules like we never let a
customer down so I think the golden rule
is when you do drop a ball Henry I mean
you just gotta shake humility you've got
to be authentic I'll share with you
something I've got any customer can I
get dm's I get probably I don't know
maybe ten to twelve contacts a month
from customers reach now personally to
me where they say you know Stephen I'm
sorry I have to escalate to you but
we've got an issue and literally I jump
on it in nanoseconds until you say
something like I'm really sorry to hear
your problem I read read the context
their problems say you know obviously
you know we have the highest highest
aspiration for you as a customer you
know you you're the reason why we exist
your power wages you our livelihood and
we absolutely do everything everything
we do everyday is front and tempts in
front and center of our business model
and it's all about customer session
however I'm really sorry on this
occasion looks like we drop the ball so
please accept my apologies and then
literally the thing you gotta do is
you've got a meet in media kind of rapid
response and sort their problem out
you've got to jump on it you gotta fly
the green berries the red berries the
second powers everybody in there the
Mounties you've got to do whatever it
takes and and it's great so this this
happens to me so on Sunday about four
weekends ago I was cut I'm driving back
from the coast and Bing and I just
stopped in a lay-by and there was a
customer who is sort of bit bent out of
shape on a Sunday night and so I had
their cell phone number on so I dialed
it and they I said our eyes is Ashley
and they said yeah and said who's this I
said it's Stephen Kelly from Sage and
they said who we thought you didn't
exist
exist I'm just a human being I'm really
sorry I've let you down it hurts me it's
all my assets just like a dagger through
my heart when we drop a ball for the
customer so I can't promise to do
anything Sunday night I promise you're
like eight o'clock tomorrow morning I'll
get someone on your case and I'll check
in at lunch time make sure we put the
fire out for you and we've solved your
problem so I kind of think there's a few
things one is be humble apologize just
show that authenticity because we're all
customers and we all expect great
service and put yourself in the shoes of
the customer secondly then is absolutely
then exceed expectations you've got to
put that fire out and and then thirdly
just a golden ruler life is always
expectation so you've neither meet or
exceed them now the good news is I
shouldn't shouldn't finish without a
really bit of good news this is the good
news story since I've been here three
and half years as chief executive I
probably had I don't know hundreds of
customers when you add up all those
customer fires we call them red alerts a
customer so and and we've done some
testing and they are 98% massive sage
advocates you know why because we drop
the ball we fixed it and they knew that
we care about them and and the reason
why I say that you as a message is when
you've had a customer where it hasn't
gone perfectly but you it's all the
great companies all have customer issues
at some point in time the really great
companies fix them without question and
they just say we'll double down your
shoulder to shoulder with you mr.
customer mrs. customer miss customer and
we'll sort things out for you mate we'll
take all your problems away there that's
the measure of a great company and you
as the entrepreneur you set the tone for
everything that happens in your company
is you hire the second third fourth
fifth employee so it's really important
that you keep that spirit around
customer obsession and I'll say it's a
great model and when you fix customer
problems they become your fans fanatical
followers of you for the rest of their
life and they'll recommend and they'll
do referrals and other customer videos
and testimonials put them on your
website because they love you because
you love them at the time when they were
in car
I was great Errol we got a we got to cut
that piece and like diet has to go on
the stage YouTube channel for minor for
I G TV that was a good that was I agree
with everything the only thing I'll add
is just a quick story of mine when I was
dealing with the I was working with a
client similar to this for like I had I
had two million of the line we're doing
a hangout and I was based in LA at the
time and the power goes out in the whole
city while we're live on air doing a
broadcast and I cut out and then he's on
by himself trying to answer questions
but and he's not Stephen Kelly so he's
not you know doesn't know what he's
doing he's super nervous Stephen doesn't
need me on this show he could just fly
and go out these rants
and I felt like there's no what can I do
you they like the internet and sorry the
power in the entire city is out I can't
do anything so I feel really bad for him
he's on the line for another ten minutes
just say you know I hope everyone comes
back it's like it's so embarrassing
public for my client here so I said I'm
really sorry we're gonna do this again
we're not gonna charge you anything
forward we're gonna give it some exit
promotion I went back to to my city I
booked the time in an internet cafe even
though my internet is rock-solid here
and never had any problems just to make
sure that there is no internet problems
and and did it again made it up to him
and to Stevens Point he's been an
ambassador like people just appreciate
the extra mile that you go to to help
them and they recognize as long as you
come with humility you say sorry like I
feel really if they feel you're genuine
care you come out with humility and as
opposed to fighting or blaming them for
something even if it's somebody on your
team
like if it's somebody on your team's
fault it's your fault always everything
that happens wrong at Sage is Stevens
fault right so like making a call is is
easy everything happens in my business
if there's somebody on my team it's my
fault yeah
and so just embracing that
responsibility and saying say yeah this
person messed up like you take it you
want it the humility and and I agree
like you'll they'll become customers for
life until other friends about you
through that negative experience a
mentally as well Evan there's only one
place you should ever point a finger
how about at the mirror you could do the
mirror yeah you could it's always your
responsibility and and it hurts you know
it's like when you let people down it
hurts the great thing about
entrepreneurs everybody listening to
this broadcast you're listening because
you care yeah and you're passionate
about doing the right thing for your
customers so it's personal Henry wrote
back he was saying thank you that was
relieving so glad that helped Henry
Stephen we're a timer right it's crazy
this is this is one of my favorite
moments the moment where Stephen puts a
bow on it ties it all together gives us
our final message on the first steps in
certain the business and mistakes to
avoid how are we gonna wrap this up
Stephen I think you know I think a
shelter from a quote one of our
customers kitty Murray founder of refuge
coffee so she talked about we believe in
doing things with people instead of for
them it's doing things with people when
you do things for people you affirm
their dignity inherently and the value
when you bring them into decision-making
and bring them right at the table you
make them feel part of it that's a great
quote because when you think about
starting your business you want to think
about the customers you're gonna attract
in the years to come and you've got to
live in their mind to imagine their
future and create something that's just
gonna change their world and Evan and I
wish you all good luck and good fortune
with your adventures loveable thank you
guys for watching sorry we didn't get to
all the questions come in early next
month when Steve and I are on again we
believe in you hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love good luck Stephen
on your ride thank you buddy
hashtag believe and we're riding for
every one of you out there and we want
to do the same thing in Canada son Tom
of the intronic one day on our bikes
I'll do it if Darrell's doing it he's
doing it all right thumbs up got a
second the work then I gotta get to work
I can't plank for anything all right
good guys Cheers